oh boy I sure love farming hey who needs
farming when you have a hovercraft oh
yeah [ __ ] you FedEx [ __ ] you doing up
FedEx stop it
FedEx forty ginger FedEx publications
that exact I can escape not on my watch
this is for never delivering my packages
in time oh yeah does this even go hello
now we're talking isn't that right busy
not wanna I want to go back came in like
a busy lift hey-oh
what something is happening I don't know
all right [ __ ] it
oh man what the how did I do that best
helicopter ever
no don't hit me motorbike stop stop okay
it's doing that thing again that I don't
know why god damn it excuse me sir [ __ ]
not not more of them but the fog stop
stop it looks like we have no choice go
Bessie kill them destroy damnit bet
Bessie you [ __ ] had to go gas
let's get that FedEx [ __ ]
destroy Bessie what are you even doing
Bessie
hey girl what's up ahh Bessie hey see
what'd I tell you
look it's the [ __ ] motorbike again I
better get him this is my [ __ ] is this
no you think I'm gonna do actual farming
in this game well then you're wrong
uh-oh oh there's a FedEx just drive yes
so the control said em and arrow up to
fly well that's not [ __ ] to work any
isn't it
oh god just go up go up go up go up go
up go up go up go up
yes yes just fly on the wings of love
fly a leak up there you piece of [ __ ]
hey girl what's up autumn don't mind me
you FedEx [ __ ] alright alright
so far so great so far it really good
can we steer this piece-of-shit plane
can we do anything in life what is this
what is this I didn't ask for this
nice nice nice shirt very classy best
smart ever Wow whoa Jesus what what just
happened I'm gonna get so many ladies
finally now that I have this oh it's
FedEx [ __ ] your FedEx [ __ ] your double
FedEx kill Wow all right price you're
ready for this it's gonna be good happy
Friday
okay I have a lot of golf carts now I
got a golf cart army sweet video game
God shut up it's so annoying let's do it
jump I want to do it Lisa jumps
alright here it comes
yeah I can say cause they got how do I
go up watch please yes yes we're flying
like it took me three hours I'm sure
this is what they intended when they
made farming simulator oh man where am I
going
all I needed was a little bounce off am
I going to space I think I'm going to
space I [ __ ] it
see you later helicopter I'm just gonna
go here that was fun hey buddy
so where's bulldozer ever I'm gonna kill
him go go playing go
what are you doing yes denne denne denne
denne denne denne denne denne did it
[ __ ] me son of a [ __ ]
why aren't you searing the [ __ ] is this
what are you even doing yeah yeah that's
right haters but you can't do a cow cow
stand
all right price that's all the time at
for today if you enjoyed this video
please hit that like button if you want
more and as always thank you boys for
watching stay on so gross jesus [ __ ]
Emma's a dream Bruce her sleeves with
her